good to see you sir how are you good
good how are you
i'm doing very well this is exciting to
talk about this movie you and maggie q
like
tear it up and yes and she's she's like
the real deal man did you feel like you
got to really push yourself and push
your limits when you were doing those
action scenes i felt like i was catching
up with her she's uh yeah she is the
real deal she's good at this stuff and
i'm saying she's also getting to i think
i'm pretty sure
place some stuff that she doesn't
normally get to play as well
instead of just being as bad as woman
you know as well as being a badass woman
but she's great she's great she's really
good in this movie it was really easy
working with her
you know i didn't have any scenes with
uh sam but uh
you know who's also great in this movie
was a big draw of this the opportunity
to
like
kick some ass
yes
because i do it so often in life
but i thought you know maybe i should do
this on screen no um he uh
it was actually it was you know i don't
play this this is not my
thing all the time american assassin yes
certainly the batman movies uh and
other you know i did a movie called one
good cop that in it has one of the truly
great fight scenes
uh that i've ever that i've
been in for sure and and seen it was
really clever fights and really
realistic fights
but i don't
you know in a couple other things but
usually this is not the thing i do all
the time lobby is
obviously me um and so so yeah it's fun
fun to see if you pull it off and make
it look and you know playing this kind
of big screen character is fun
so a lot of ice baths at the end of a
long shoot day
man
it's to me for me maggie probably like
went out like you know when dancing or
something me man
i was icing up
i was
recording
[Music]
you know you mentioned the batman movies
obviously over the years you've been
asked so many times about like what do
you think about this actor's performance
is batman what do you think about that
actor's performance is batman are you
excited for fans
to get to see like multiple batman
yourself and ben's batman on screen
in the flash
uh i don't guess i don't think about it
i don't i'm i'm just excited to do it
but i don't i don't know that i'm
excited i don't know that i think about
what are they going to think about all
those all those things you just
mentioned
right yeah i mean speaking as one i will
tell you that i am excited for it so
that's very cool yeah no it's it's good
it's i i i feel confident in saying that
you know uh
uh and it was fun
it's fun
excellent sir thank you so much for your
time all right um congratulations on
this film and yeah you you do kick a lot
of ass knows very cool to say thanks
very much